[Music]
no it's starting to smell more and more
like collusion - I think the public if
they just do their work and do their job
they will find out it was collusion and
I believe this president should be
impeached I don't care what others say
about it's too soon we don't know we
think what more do we need well for more
than a year we've listened to elected
Democrats and the media who assiduously
serve them how about Russian collusion
and why we need a far-reaching
all-powerful investigation to uncover it
and now your unpatriotic if you've got
questions about that well we got our
investigation and has not found a whiff
of evidence that anybody and the Trump
campaign colluded with Vladimir Putin so
now these same people have been yelling
at us for a year about this have decided
to forget they ever said anything like
this they're now claiming collusion was
never the point at all they just want to
know more about what Russia was doing
House Intelligence Chairman Devin Nunez
has been closely involved in
investigation obviously from the very
beginning and he joins us tonight mr.
chairman thanks coming up
always a pleasure Tucker thank you so um
you've requested a number of documents
from federal agencies intelligence and
law enforcement agencies and apparently
haven't got them why is it so difficult
to get facts from our government well
it's been a challenge as you know the
whole time we've had to subpoena we've
had to threaten contempt but this is
what this is kind of we're having a
showdown between the legislative branch
and the executive branch and just going
to what you talked about to open up this
segment the facts are not varying out to
what the Democrats wanted it to be
because we have found collusion
we found collusion between the Democrats
specifically the Clinton campaign and
the Democratic National Committee and
the Russians however it doesn't seem to
be like that nobody's interested in that
collusion we've also found felony leaks
nobody seems to be interested in getting
to bottom of the felony leaks so it's
part of what House Intelligence
Committee led by the Republicans are
trying to get to the bottom of right
despite we're up against a lot of
we're not getting help from the
Democrats in the house and we're also
not getting any help from the mainstream
media so which is so here's an example
of the line going on
so John Brennan former CIA director
comes before Congress and testifies
under oath that he had no idea who wrote
the Trump dossier and that that dossier
formed the basis of no conclusions by
the Intel community seems very much like
a lie because the FBI knew exactly who
wrote that dossier
he lied to Congress under oath you see
gonna face perjury charges for that and
if not why not well one of the things
that we did today is we sent out a
questionnaire and we asked we're asking
several former and current officials to
answer ten simple questions and these
are questions that the public not only
you should know and have a right to know
but I think they what they want to know
and that is when did simple questions
like when did you learn about the
dossier when did you learn that it was
paid for by the Democrats when did you
learn that this was a political piece I
mean these are all questions that we
should be able to get answers to and we
will so part of what we sent out today
was with the questionnaire with ten
questions on it also was a cover letter
that says if you don't answer this we're
giving him a couple weeks to answer it
you will be subpoenaed and you will come
before Congress to tell us when you knew
about this but Brennan did already say
what he I mean he said his piece and it
looks really clear that he lied is he
gonna do you think he lied well we don't
know right I mean we don't know the
answer to I mean maybe he's telling the
truth I don't know did he not know that
the Democrats paid for the dossier it's
possible now one of the things he said
on another show was that he knew that he
was press people were talking to him
about the dossier in 2016 now we don't
know who those press people were we
don't it's possible he didn't know the
Democrats paid for it at that time they
really he knew about the dossier way
back in in 1916 the FBI knew Sherman
thank you for coming on including that
stuff up I appreciate it